[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend ihnen Wahlen allein machen noch
keine Demokratie sie entscheidet sich
immer dann wenn ein Machtwechsel ansteht
und da müssen wir in letzter Zeit ja
plötzlich bangen erst der 6 januar vor
zwei Jahren in den USA als seine
gewalttätige Menge angestachelt vom
abgewählten Präsidenten das Parlament
stürmte gestern dann eine massive
Attacke auf die demokratischen
Institutionen von Brasilien radikale
Anhänger des abgewählten Präsidenten
Parlament Gerichtshof und Regierungssitz
in Brasilia ein und hinterlassen schwere
Verwüstungen die Folgen für die
Demokratie besprechen wir gleich erst
die aktuelle Lage von Oliver Heuchert
berittene Polizei in Brasilia am Tag
danach hunderte schwer bewaffnete
Polizisten greifen durch Räumen das
Protestcamp der bolsonaro-anhänger in
der Hauptstadt
massenweise werden sie festgenommen der
Justizminister spricht von 1.200
Personen in Gewahrsam
Präsident Louis signatio lulla das
silver demonstriert derweil Normalität
und tagt heute mit seiner Regierung
genau da wo gestern noch der Mob tobte
im Regierungspalast
den Journalisten wird das Ausmaß der
Schäden vorgeführt zerstört wurde
offensichtlich alles was nicht Nied und
nagelfest war die Empörung über diesen
Angriff auf die Demokratie ist weltweit
egal wo auf der Welt Demokratien
angegriffen werden ist dies immer auch
ein Angriff auf unsere Freiheit und auf
unsere Werte daher gilt unsere ganze
Solidarität dem brasilianischen Volk
Generalsekretär Antonio guteres schreibt
auf Twitter ich verurteile den Angriff
auf die demokratischen Institutionen
Brasiliens der heute stattgefunden hat
der Wille des brasilianischen Volkes und
die demokratischen Institutionen müssen
respektiert werden
die Gewalt gestern gegen die zentralen
Institutionen der brasilianischen
Demokratie hat sich schon jetzt in die
Geschichte Brasiliens eingebrannt
zerstört was sie vorfanden und es gab zu
wenig Sicherheitskräfte wir werden
herausfinden wer dafür verantwortlich
ist
es dauerte gestern lange bis die Polizei
wirklich Eingriff bis sie den Angreifern
wirklich etwas entgegensetzte
der Mann dem die Täter von gestern
anhängen verfolgt das Treiben vom fernen
Florida aus hier besucht der vergangene
Woche einen Supermarkt in Holländer
auf der Straße in Florida stößt
bolzenaru durchaus auf Sympathien
zumindest in der vergangenen Woche zu
den Unruhen in seiner Heimat Schwieger
gestern stundenlang bis er folgendes auf
Twitter schrieb friedliche
Demonstrationen sind Teil der Demokratie
Plünderungen und Überfälle auf
öffentliche Gebäude wie sie heute
stattgefunden haben fallen jedoch nicht
darunter
der Angriff gestern war nichts weniger
als ein Umsturzversuch vielleicht sogar
der Versuch einen Militärputsch zu
provozieren stand heute ist dieses
Vorhaben erst einmal gescheitert
fangen wir nochmal nach bei Christoph
röckerath in Rio de Janeiro und am
Christoph bolzonaros Anhänger hatten die
Attacken ja seit mindestens zwei Wochen
geplant überraschend für Polizei und
Armee kann das also nicht gewesen sein
haben denn die Gewalttäter auch dort
Sympathisanten ist Brasilien garen eine
Militärputsch vorbeigeschrammt
also auf den zweiten Teil der Frage
einzugehen ich glaube nicht dass
brasilient ein militärputschtrot dafür
hat sich der Generalstab des Militärs
einfach seit der Wahl doch zu deutlich
zurückgehalten es waren gestern auch
keine Militärs beteiligt es waren
ausschließlich Zivilisten
bolzenario-anhänger die dort randaliert
haben und ich habe auch nicht das Gefühl
dass hier in Brasilien eine große Putsch
oder umbruchstimmung wirklich in der
Bevölkerung ist im Gegenteil ich glaube
die meisten sehen sich eher nach Ruhe
und einer Rückkehr zur Sachpolitik dafür
war auch das Echo auf die Angriffe von
gestern hier viel zu verheerend in
weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung und in
diesen Minuten gehen auch mehrere
Demonstrationen mehreren Städten los
wofür die Demokratie demonstriert werden
soll also da siehe ich eigentlich nicht
unbedingt eine Gefahr es gibt aber in
der Tat einen großen dezent zwischen der
neuen Bundesregierung Luna und den
regionalen und landespolizeibehörden zum
Teil der neue Justizminister hat heute
eine Pressekonferenz gehalten indem er
erklärt hat dass man sehr wohl gewusst
habe das gewaltbereite Nahrung Anhänger
sich auf Brasilia zu bewegen und habe
dann mit den für die Sicherheit der
Hauptstadt vollständigen Landesbehörden
einen Plan erarbeitet wie die Hauptstadt
zu schützen sei und dieser ist
anscheinend sagt die Justizminister
nicht umgesetzt worden es waren viel zu
wenig Sicherheitskräfte am Ort wir haben
viel zu spät eingeschritten es gibt ja
sogar Bilder dass einige der Polizisten
scheinbar gemeinsame Sache mit den
Randalierern gemacht haben und jetzt
wird es darum gehen woran das lag war
das Unvermögen oder war da
möglicherweise sogar politisch
motivierte Absicht dahinter der
zuständige Sicherheitschef es gestern
Abend noch abgesetzt worden der
zuständige Gouverneur ist suspendiert
worden jetzt wird ermittelt um genau
diese doch sehr kritische Frage zu
klären und dann gibt's natürlich noch
eine andere Frage nämlich welche Rolle
spielt bolsonaro selbst der aktuell ja
in Florida ist
es gibt keine nachweisbare Äußerung die
bolzenaru konkret mit den Ereignissen
von gestern in Form eines Aufrufes etwa
verbinden könnten man weiß aber
natürlich dass er ein Social Media Profi
ist und viele Beobachter hier sagen dass
jetzt einfach die Saat aufgeht hier in
den letzten vier Jahren gesät hat er hat
ja immer wieder seine Anhänger in
Aufregung gehalten all die Jahre über
immer wieder dieses narrativ von wir
gegen alle anderen gepflegt hat
politische Gegner aufs Übelste
diffamieren lassen teilweise auch mit
Fake News Kampagnen regelrecht
demontiert und das ganze sieht man jetzt
auch daran dass er zum Beispiel auch zur
Wahl gar nicht viel sagen musste er hat
Lula nicht gratuliert zur Wahl nicht mit
klaren Worten sondern Niederlage
eingeräumt er stattdessen angedeutet
dass es vielleicht sogar Wahlfälschung
geben könnte und jetzt ist die Frage ob
da nicht längst eine Gruppe eine
sektenartige Gruppe entstanden ist die
fast schon als Selbstläufer da unterwegs
war gestern ohne irgendwas sagen muss
vielleicht eine ganz kleine Sache noch
die das auch belegen kann oder zumindest
helfen kann das zu verstehen jetzt wo
die Schäden so groß sind das Ausmaß der
Verwüstung auch von Kunst sagen mit
entsprechendem Entsetzen verbreiten halt
diese gleichen Gruppen dass sie das gar
nicht selber waren sondern das linke
sich als bolzenario-anhänger verkleidet
haben und den ganzen Vandalismus
angezettelt haben um ihnen zu schaden
also das zeigt so ein bisschen was da
auch für eine Gruppe entstanden ist die
große Frage ist wie groß ist diese
Gruppe und wie fängt man die wieder ein
ein Wahnsinn vielen Dank für diese
Analyse Christoph nach Rio de Janeiro
2022 war kein gutes Jahr um eigene
Akzente zu setzen in der Politik es war
das Jahr in dem praktisch jeder
Entscheidung bestand aus purem
Krisenmanagement jetzt setzt die
Berliner Ampelkoalition voll auf 2023
und merkt gleich auch das wird nicht
ganz einfach denn alle drei Partner
stehen unter Druck inhaltlich in die
Offensive kommen die jeweils eigenen
Umfragewerte verbessern eine Reihe von
Personalsorgen klären auch der FDP-Chef
und Bundesfinanzminister sieht sich
aktuell mit Fragen konfrontiert dabei
geht es um eine mögliche Verquickung mit
privaten Interessen bei einer
Hausfinanzierung die Ampel sorgen Klaus
brodbeer
Jahresauftakt Parteispitzen lieben das
bei jeder Partei kurz sind Klausur dann
auftritt dann großes Lob vor allem für
das selbst erreichtte reihenweise
Erfolge hängt die SPD in ihren Himmel
erklären muss der Vorsitzende anderes
wie etwa findet seine Partei die eigene
Verteidigungsministerin wir haben nicht
das Verhalten von Ministern bewertet wir
haben nicht darüber geredet wer wie was
besser machen könnte oder kann Christine
lamprechtsnamen lieber mal nicht
ausgesprochen vertrauensbeweise klingen
anders ihre Krise sieht sich weiter dann
doch lieber zurück zum Knatsch der
Koalitionäre und von den anderen fordern
genau diesen zu beenden Beispiel
Verkehrswende ich akzeptiere ja das ist
unterschiedliche Perspektiven gibt aber
wofür keine Zeit haben ist diese
Verkantung die ich jetzt seit Wochen bei
einem so wichtigen Thema wieder erlebe
es geht gegen FDP und Grüne auch die
hatten Klausur und wollten sich lieber
loben
geht aber nicht aber die zentrale
Aufgabe ist das was wir alles
miteinander hinbekommen haben gerissen
bekommen nicht auf offener Bühne selbst
zu zerreden drei ungleiche Partner alle
mit dem gleichen Problem es passt nur
schwer man ist gestartet als die
fortschrittskoalition ist jetzt eine
krisenbewältigungskoalition die sich
eigentlich täglich neu austarieren muss
und das prägt natürlich die Dynamik
innerhalb der Ampel enorm Aufsehen
erregt er den man heute im politischen
Berlin nicht zu sehen bekommt Christian
Lindner schon zuvor als Gastredner bei
der Veranstaltungen der badischen
beamtenbank gebucht gratulierte als
Finanzminister im April dem Institut per
videogrußwort zu dessen 100-jährigen
Bestehen die BBBank ist mir von Grund
auf sympathisch denn ihre Geschichte
begann mit einem Akt der Eigeninitiative
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sollten
Finanzierungen erhalten und Eigentum
bilden können bekannt wurde nun das
Lindner davor und danach bei der Bank
Kredite insgesamt in Millionenhöhe für
sein Eigenheim in guter Berliner Lage
aufgenommen hat das Finanzministerium
verweist auf die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Berlin diese
prüft ob sie Ermittlungen aufnehmen muss
so was ist sicherlich persönlich enorm
belastend es belastet auch die Koalition
aber es gilt die Unschuldsvermutung und
die Staatsanwaltschaft arbeitet und da
gilt es jetzt erstmal abzuwarten welche
Ergebnisse vorliegen werden
Lindners Anwalt weist jeden Zusammenhang
zwischen Grußwort und Krediten zurück
SPD und Grüne Stärken Lindner den Rücken
angepasst und da habe ich keine
Ratschläge zu erteilen was mich angeht
und was die SPD-Spitze angeht kann ich
nur sagen wir arbeiten eng und
vertrauensvoll mit Christian Lindner
zusammen also sollte ist eine Kabinett
zum Bildung geben verstehen sie das zu
hören
das nicht Lindner bringt sich und die
FDP unter Druck ein schwieriger Start
ins neue Jahr
so wir haben gehört der
Bundesfinanzminister weiß die Vorwürfe
zurück sarattacke ist bei uns unsere
Rechtsexpertin guten Abend
natürlich man kann sich oft genug sagen
gilt auch hier die Unschuldsvermutung
gucken wir doch erstmal an welcher
Stelle sind wir denn überhaupt im Moment
in diesem juristischen Prozedere in der
Sache genau wir haben sie noch mit
vorermittlung zu tun das heißt
Ermittlung bevor überhaupt ein
offizielles Ermittlungsverfahren
eröffnet wird das ist die
geringstmögliche Verdacht den es
überhaupt gibt und nur wenn die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Berlin nun zum
Ergebnis kommt ja wir sehen da
hinreichende tatsächlich Anhaltspunkte
das eine Straftat vorliegen könnte nur
dann wieder überhaupt ersten offizielles
Ermittlungsverfahren eröffnet aber da
sind wir nicht also ganz am Anfang noch
welche Frage steht denn jetzt für die
Staatsanwaltschaft im Mittelpunkt bei
ihren Prüfung die Staatsanwaltschaft
muss jetzt drei zentrale Fragen klären
erste zentrale Frage ist das Grußwort
hat Christian Lindner dieses Grußwort in
seiner Funktion als Finanzminister
gehalten was also eine Dienstausübung
und selbst wenn sie Ergebnis kommen
sollte ja und auch da ist es noch nicht
bewiesen aber selbst wenn sie zu mir
gibt es kommt ja ist die Frage hat er
ein privaten Vorteil dass die zweite
zentrale Frage also hätte jemand anderes
mit einer ähnlichen Kreditwürdigkeit der
aber kein Grußwort gehalten hat auch so
einen Kredit bekommen wenn es diesen
privaten Vorteil gegeben haben sollte
auch das noch nicht bewiesen aber selbst
wenn das der Fall sein sollte ist die
dritte zentrale Frage gab es eine
stillschweigende Vereinbarung zwischen
Christian Lindner und der Bank Grußwort
gegen günstigen Kredit alle drei Fragen
nicht bewiesen und das zeigt auch wie
weit wir noch von einem vorwärtbaren
strafbaren Vorwurf entfernt sind dann
gucken wir noch mal Sachen noch mal ganz
generell wie hoch ist denn die Hürde um
überhaupt in Deutschland beweisen zu
können ob jemand da im Amt einen Vorteil
erlangt hat grundsätzlich geht in
Deutschland bestrafen wir Korruption
sehr streng in Deutschland gilt der
Grundsatz dass selbst der anscheinend
käuflich zu sein für Amtsträger strafbar
sein kann und das auch wenn sich jemand
nur das Wohlwollen eines Amtsträgers und
das muss nicht Minister sein das kann
auch ein Polizist sein das kann auch ein
Bürgermeister sein es kann auch ein
Lehrer sein wenn sich jemand das
Wohlwollen erkauft schon das kann
strafbar sein und auch dann wenn die
Gegenleistung legales Verhalten ist also
ein Grußwort halten machen Minister
ständig das ist völlig üblich das ist
völlig legal trotzdem kann es im
Einzelfall strafbare Korruption sein ob
das im Fall Lindlar so ist das ist alles
andere als bewiesen das prüft aktuell
die Staatsanwaltschaft Sarah vielen Dank
für diese Hintergründe wichtige
Hintergründe auch heute Abend wieder bei
uns Sarah Tacke unsere Rechtsexperte so
und Hanna du guckst jetzt auf weitere
wichtige Nachrichten heute an diesem
Montag ja und dazu gehört auch die
Debatte um die Lieferung von westlichen
Kampfpanzern an die Ukraine Polen hat
nun angeregt dass eine breite Koalition
von mehreren Ländern Kampfpanzer zur
Verfügung stellt und auch
koalitionspolitikerinnen und Politiker
von Grünen und FDP sprachen sich für
eine Lieferung aus
Regierungssprecher hier bestreit äußerte
sich dagegen heute ablehnend die
Bundesregierung habe zum jetzigen den
Punkt kein Bestreben Leopard 2
Kampfpanzer an die Ukraine zu liefern
wegen der massiven Angriffe auf
Einsatzkräfte in der Berliner
Silvesternacht laufen derzeit insgesamt
102 Verfahren 22 sein bereits an die
Staatsanwaltschaft übergeben worden das
sagte heute die Berliner
Polizeipräsidentin Slowik im
Innenausschuss des Abgeordnetenhauses
die Polizei arbeite mit Hochdruck an der
Aufklärung bei der Auswertung des
umfangreichen Videomaterials würden auch
sogenannte super-nizer eingesetzt die
überdurchschnittlich gut Gesichter
wiedererkennen
wegen der Silvester Krawalle aber auch
mit Blick auf die Großrazzia gegen die
reichsbürgerszene im Dezember plant
bundesinnenministerin Fräser eine
Verschärfung des Waffenrechts laut einem
Gesetzentwurf aus dem mehrere Medien
zitieren sollen halbautomatische Waffen
künftig für Privatleute verboten werden
und für den Besitz einer
Schreckschusspistole oder eine Armbrust
soll ein kleiner Waffenschein nötig sein
der Entwurf geht laut einer Sprecherin
des Innenministeriums nun in die
Ressortabstimmung
nach der Festnahme von zwei Iranern in
Castrop-Rauxel wegen Terrorverdacht sind
bei der Durchsuchung von zwei Garagen
keine Giftstoffe gefunden worden dabei
wurden von den Spezialkräften auch
Roboter eingesetzt die beiden Brüder
sitzen in Untersuchungshaft ihnen wird
die Planung eines Anschlags vorgeworfen
sie sollen versucht haben sich dafür
Cyanid und Rizin zu beschaffen
US-Präsident beiden ist nach Mexiko
gereist um mit der Regierung dort
gemeinsam mit Kanada über den künftigen
Umgang mit Migranten zu beraten er will
erreichen dass weniger Menschen illegal
aus Süd- und Mittelamerika in die USA
kommen um dort zu leben oder Asyl zu
beantragen zum Auftakt der Gespräche
deutete mexikos Präsident Lopes Obrador
an den USA Entgegenkommen zu wollen es
Präsident beiden will tausende Migranten
nach Mexiko zurückschicken Konflikt
wirkt ein weiteres Vorhaben Mexiko zum
sicheren Drittstaat zu erklären
Einreisende von dort hätten dann keinen
Anspruch mehr auf Asyl in den USA
Deutschland im wartemodus weil überall
Personal fehlt wer kurzfristig
Handwerker braucht bekommt nur ein
mühles Lächeln in Restaurants und
Kneipen gibt es verzweifelte
Stellenangebote auf den Flughäfen lädt
nur noch eine Rumpfmannschaft das Gepäck
aus die Folge für die Reisenden absurde
Wartezeiten vom Fachkräftemangel der
Industrie und Gesundheitswesen in
Alarmstimmung versetzt noch gar nicht zu
reden auf der anderen Seite hat
Deutschland immer noch ein Heer von
Arbeitslosen davon viele die seit Jahren
ohne Arbeit sind wie passt das zusammen
Oliver
es ist 7 Uhr morgens noch dunkel
Nieselregen die Gärtner auf dem
waldeckhof in Göppingen bei der Staufen
Beschäftigungsgesellschaft packen ihre
Geräte zusammen diese Männer haben lange
Arbeitslosigkeit hinter sich Leiharbeit
massenweise Bewerbungen auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt haben sie kaum
chancenter und
[Musik]
das haben sie in Syrien gemacht ich habe
einen Siri gemacht 25 Jahre schneller
gearbeitet
aber an der Stadt hat keine Schneide
derzeit werden in Deutschland 870.000
Langzeitarbeitslose gezählt diese
Menschen sind oft wenig oder falsch
qualifiziert oder sie sind älter oder
Ihnen für den Sprachkenntnisse oder Sie
haben gesundheitliche Probleme auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt aber sind möglichst
qualifizierte Menschen gesucht deswegen
greife die Gegenüberstellung von
Langzeitarbeitslosen und dem
Fachkräftemangel zu kurz meint die
Chefin der Arbeitsagentur
es ist einfach nicht fair das wird der
unterstellt als ob das alles
Arbeitsunwillige Menschen sind und das
können wir aus unserer Praxis wirklich
nicht bestätigen die gute Nachricht zu
diesem Thema die Zahl der
Langzeitarbeitslosen singt seit ihrem
Höhepunkt mit 1,9 Millionen 2006 um mehr
als die Hälfte auf 870.000 auch wenn
Kurve zwischenzeitlich für einen kurzen
wieder einstiegte
das heißt aber auch dass die übrigen
Langzeitarbeitslosen eher diejenigen
sind die mit besonders vielen
Schwierigkeiten zu kämpfen haben und
dann irgendwann zu einer
Beschäftigungsgesellschaft wie hier in
Göppingen kommen
vorher habe ich lange Zeit nichts
gemacht
bin dann übers Arbeitsamt in die
Maßnahme komme also auf dem Waldhof
haben sie gesundheitliche
Schwierigkeiten
ja die hat den Schlaganfall
also jetzt dieses Jahr im Ende Juli
der Kreis der Menschen die keinen Zugang
zum Arbeitsmarkt finden ist allerdings
viel größer als der der
Langzeitarbeitslosen
derzeit beziehen rund 5,37 Millionen
Menschen Bürgergeld die meisten von
ihnen stehen dem Arbeitsmarkt nicht zur
Verfügung 1,5 Millionen sind Kinder gut
800.000 sind Aufstocker die bereits
arbeiten aber weniger als das
Existenzminimum für denen knapp 700.000
betreuen Kinder andere Angehörige oder
sind in einer Ausbildung mehr als
400.000 befinden sich in einer Maßnahme
und 250.000 sind krank der Rest
1,72 Millionen ist tatsächlich
arbeitslos davon rund zur Hälfte
langzeitarbeitslos die andere Hälfte
findet innerhalb eines Jahres eine
Stelle
zumindest einen Teil der
langzeitarbeitslosenden Arbeit zu
bringen wird versucht doch alle wissen
es ist ein weiter Weg
trotz Arbeitslosigkeit gibt es also
einen Arbeits- und Fachkräftemangel in
Deutschland und das wollen wir uns noch
einmal vertiefend anschauen mit Valerie
Haller in Frankfurt Valerie wo fehlen
denn aktuell besonders viele Fachkräfte
und welche Ansätze gibt es um das
Problem zu lösen in ganz ganz vielen
Bereichen vielen Fachkräfte im Verkehr
Einzelhandel Gesundheitswesen die
mitunter meisten offenen Stellen hat das
Handwerk und lange unbesetzt bleiben
Stellen im Bereich der Altenpflege ja
unternehmen können viel gegen
Fachkräftemangel tun mit finanziellen
Anreizen flexiblen Arbeitszeiten
Homeoffice einige haben aber auch
spezielle Ausbildungsprogramme für
Fachfremde eingerichtet oder sie
ermöglichen arbeiten über Landesgrenzen
hinaus auf der anderen Seite ist
natürlich auch die Politik gefragt mit
verbesserten Betreuungsangeboten für
Kinder um mehr Menschen aus der Teilzeit
zu holen und natürlich mit Zuwanderung
nun mangelt das aber eben nicht nur an
den hochqualifizierten Arbeitskräften ja
auch die Gastronom zum Beispiel klagt
dass sie keine Leute findet und
ähnliches gilt auch für das
Flughafenpersonal ja genau inzwischen
geht es um eine ganz grundsätzliche
Personalknappheit neben der Demografie
hat auch die Pandemie den Arbeitsmarkt
verändert in einigen Branchen war die
Unsicherheit besonders groß also in der
schon erwähnten Gastronomie in der
Hotellerie sind Arbeitskräfte während
Corona abgewandert einige sind zu
Testzentren Lieferdiensten oder in die
Logistik gegangen also alles Bereiche
die in der Krise gewachsen sind aber
ganz grundsätzlich gilt viele
Beschäftigte sind wählerischer geworden
wer heute Arbeitskräfte sucht muss
einfach mehr bieten als früher vielen
Dank Valerie
die Räumung des besetzten Ortes
lützerath im rheinischen Braunkohle
Revier soll noch in dieser Woche
beginnen frühestens am Mittwoch das gab
die Aachener Polizei bekannt man stelle
sich auf einen Einsatz mit erheblichen
Risiken ein so die Polizei die Räumung
werde voraussichtlich vier Wochen dauern
in den verlassenen Gebäuden von
lützerath Leben hunderte klimaaktivisten
die verhindern wollen dass das Dorf für
den Braunkohleabbau abgerissen wird
gestern waren nach einer Versammlung
Polizisten mit Steinen beworfen worden
nach den katastrophalen Überschwemmungen
in Pakistan im vergangenen Sommer hat
das Land bei einer UN-Konferenz nach
eigenen Angaben mehr als 9 Milliarden
Dollar an hilfs zu sagen erhalten und
damit deutlich mehr als erwartet
Deutschland stockte die Hilfe um weitere
84 Millionen Euro auf insgesamt benötigt
das südasiatische Land nach Schätzungen
der UN etwa 16 Milliarden Dollar für den
Wiederaufbau stark haben und Sohn Regen
hatte in den Sommermonaten dazu geführt
dass ein Drittel Pakistans unter Wasser
stand er als 1.700 Menschen kamen ums
Leben Millionen wurden obdachlos
das sind die Bilder die aus dem Iran
seit vielen vielen Wochen um die Welt
gehen die Wut von Demonstrantinnen und
Demonstranten die genug haben von der
Herrschaft der mullers
in deutschen Kinos ist ab dieser Woche
ein bemerkenswerter Blick zu sehen
hinter die Kulissen eines Systems das
Frauen grundsätzlich abwertet es ist der
Film eines iranischen Regisseurs der
nicht mehr im Iran lebt mit iranischen
Schauspielern die ins Ausland gehen
mussten gedreht in Jordanien als
internationale Ko-Produktion die für
Dänemark einen Oscar holen soll und
trotz alledem oder gerade deswegen so
viel sagt über ihre holy Spider heißt
der film Nadja nasser hat ihn gesehen
Iran 2001 in der heiligen Pilgerstadt
Maschad treibt ein Serienmörder seit
einem Jahr sein Unwesen immer auf der
Suche nach Prostituierten in seinen
Augen sittenlose und damit wertlose
Frauen
der sogenannte spinnenmörder nimmt sie
mit zu sich und er wirkt sie mit ihren
Kopftüchern tief überzeugt damit auf
göttlicher Mission zu sein am Ende wird
er 16 Frauen umgebracht haben
die Journalistin are surahimi reist nach
Maschad um über die Mordserie zu
berichten aber als alleinstehende Frau
stößt sie überall auf Widerstand
für mich ganz allein ja ein Moment bitte
es tut mir sehr leid das scheint in
unserem System ein Fehler passiert zu
sein wenn Sie bitte Ihre Haare bedecken
würden das ist meine Sache
seit Beginn der islamischen Revolution
im Iran 1979 hat die Regierung ein
mächtiges System der Geschlechter
Apartheit installiert die Art wie das
Regime Frauen unterdrückt ist nicht nur
diskriminierend sie reicht in alle
Bereiche der Gesellschaft hinein ist so
umfassend und steckt tief in jeder Phase
des Systems
[Musik]
dieser Kerl bringt zehn Frauen um alle
auf dieselbe Weise legt die Leichen am
selben Ort ab und ist immer noch frei
seltsam oder
er hat auch Freunde are so ist sich
sicher der Prostituierten Mörder wird
von der religiösen Führung gedeckt es
gibt diejenigen die von einfachen Morden
reden aber für andere steckt etwas
anderes dahinter wenn es keine Morde
sind was dann es heißt diese diese
Person geht nach einer Art Vater vor
ich werde hier keinen Skandal zulassen
ich kann Ihnen nur raten vorsichtig zu
sein wir haben diese Morde sind ja
tatsächlich vor 20 Jahren im Iran verübt
worden und heute sind wir auf einmal an
einem Punkt an dem alles explodiert und
die Leute sagen wir können nicht mehr
wir wollen dass sich unsere Gesellschaft
endlich ändert so kann es nicht
weitergehen und jetzt gehen die Menschen
auf die Straße unser riskieren dort ihr
Leben für eine bessere Zukunft für sich
und andere
im Film riskiert are so schließlich ihr
Leben als Lockvogel um den Täter zu
stellen damit nicht noch mehr Frauen
sterben müssen
ein Film durch die Proteste im Iran für
mehr Frauenrechte aktueller denn je
zeigt er doch brutal und schonungslos
was Frauenfeindlichkeit und Fanatismus
anrichten können
einige von denen die diesen Film gemacht
haben bekamen Besuch von iranischen
Sicherheitsleuten der Hauptdarsteller
konnte nicht mehr zurück in den Iran und
lebt jetzt in Europa der Film so sagt
sein Regisseur hat viele Menschen eine
Menge gekostet es lohnt ihn zu sehen am
Donnerstag hier bei uns im Kino und dann
schauen wir jetzt noch aufs
Fernsehprogramm ja auch das lohnt sich
da gibt es nämlich um 0.25 unser heute
journal Update zu sehen mit Nazan göktem
Abend
[Musik]
gutes neues Jahr wenn Sie die Eiseskälte
im Winter vermessen dann zeige ich Ihnen
mal wo die gerade zu finden ist nämlich
hier am Ural da liegen morgen die
Höchsttemperaturen bei minus 30 Grad von
dieser Kälte bekommen wir aber nichts
mit und das liegt an der Kombination aus
hoch und tiefsten bei uns kommt die
Strömung aus Westen aus Südwesten nur
ganz vorübergehend mal aus Nordwesten
dann wird es vorübergehend mal kälter
jetzt aktuell fällt ja so ein bisschen
Schnee z.B Schwarzwald oder auch in den
Alpen morgen lassen diese Schneefälle
nach und dann kommt schon gleich das
nächste Tief auf uns zu eine kleine
Warmfront da kann es dann höchstens in
den Gipfel lagen wieder für etwas Schnee
reichen wir auch in dieser Nacht im
Schwarzwald oberhalb von 600 Meter fällt
etwas Schnee oder auch im Allgäu sonst
regnet es oft zwischen der Donau und der
Nordsee und auch hier in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern der Wind kommt
das westlichen Richtungen so wird es
wieder eine milde Nacht sein die
Temperaturen sinken auf fünf Grad hier
in der Lüneburger Heide z.B und 0 Grad
am Alpen hat morgen gegen die
Höchsttemperaturen bei drei Grad an den
Alpen und 10 Grad am Niederrhein und
morgen Vormittag kann es noch etwas
schneien oder es fällt etwas Schneeregen
hier in Südostbayern beides sieht dann
aber ostwärts ab dann wechseln viele
Wolken mit etwas Sonne ab und dann kommt
die neue Front hier von besten heran
bringt Regen vielleicht in der Eifel
auch mal etwas schneering mit und in den
nächsten Tagen wird es kräftig weiter
regnen bis zum Wochenende so 50 bis 100
Liter pro Quadratmeter im Westen und im
Süden Deutschlands kleinere Bäche und
Flüsse werden da über die Ufer treten
guten Abend